This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars and this is Eric Mollensky. Hi, I'm Eric. Eric is an independent producer in New York City. Brooklyn, of course, like most public radio producers here. But before Brooklyn, Eric spent 10 years in Los Angeles. Yeah, when I was in LA, I used to hear this story pretty often. And the story, it's almost like a fable. LA had this amazing transportation system called the Red Car, and it was this trolley that covered the entire city. And then after World War II, either Ford or GM, Botha Red Car had it dismantled and then built this horrible freeway system that created the sprawl and gridlock of today. And you know, the first time I heard this story I thought, well that sounds familiar,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯，这位是埃里克·莫林斯基。嗨，我是埃里克。埃里克是纽约市的一名独立制作人。当然是在布鲁克林，就像这里大多数公共广播制作人一样。但在布鲁克林之前，埃里克在洛杉矶待了10年。是的，当我在洛杉矶时，我经常听到这个故事。这个故事简直就像个寓言。洛杉矶曾经有一个很棒的交通系统，叫“红车”，那是一种覆盖全城的电车。二战后，福特或通用汽车，或者两者联手，拆除了红车，然后修建了现在这种糟糕的高速公路系统，造成了今天的城市蔓延和交通拥堵。你知道，我第一次听到这个故事时，我想，嗯，这听起来很耳熟，
it must be true, I feel like I've definitely heard this story before. That's because it's the plot of who framed Roger Rapids. Oh, man! Now he raises the human! Or at least it's the evil scheme that Christopher Lloyd reveals at the end of the movie. Come on! Nobody's gonna drive this lousy freeway when they can take the red car for a nickel! Oh, they'll drive. They'll have to. You see, I bought the red car, so I could dismantle it.
它一定是真的，我觉得我肯定以前听过这个故事。那是因为这就是电影《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》的情节。天哪！现在他提到了那个人！或者至少，这是克里斯托弗·洛伊德在电影结尾揭露的邪恶计划。得了吧！当人们可以花五分钱坐红车时，没人会去开那破高速公路！哦，他们会开的。他们不得不开。你看，我买下了红车，就是为了拆掉它。
What the... This isn't totally ridiculous. Remember the plot of Chinatown where Los Angeles mogul was stealing water from Northern California? That actually happened. Forget it, Jake, it's Chinatown. As I learned more about the history of LA, I learned that the red car was actually not the victim of a massive conspiracy. The red car actually was the conspiracy.
什么鬼……这完全不是胡扯。还记得《唐人街》的情节吗？洛杉矶的大亨从北加州偷水？那可是真实发生过的。算了吧，杰克，那是唐人街。随着我对洛杉矶历史了解得越多，我发现红车其实并不是一场巨大阴谋的受害者。红车本身就是那个阴谋。
The red car helped create the sprawl in the gridlock. To understand how this all came about, we have to go way back to the mid-19th century. A boy named Henry Huntington was born into a middle class family in upstate New York, but he has a very wealthy uncle named Collis Huntington. Collis has no kids, and he sort of latches on to his nephew.
红车助长了城市的蔓延和交通拥堵。要了解这一切是如何发生的，我们必须追溯到19世纪中叶。一个叫亨利·亨廷顿的男孩出生在纽约州北部的一个中产阶级家庭，但他有一位非常有钱的叔叔，叫科利斯·亨廷顿。科利斯没有孩子，他有点缠上了他的侄子。
And I mean, I assume you must see something in Henry, you know, he thinks his kid can be molded into a business man and he's right. And so, Kolas takes little Henry under his wing, he teaches him everything about the family business, which is railroads. Jump to 1900, Kolas dies, and Henry thinks he's going to inherit the company Southern Pacific. But the board doesn't want another huntiton in charge, so Henry's out. And he gets a consolation prize, which is $50 million, which back then
我的意思是，我想你一定在亨利身上看到了什么，你知道，他认为这个孩子可以被塑造成一个商人，他是对的。于是，科利斯把小亨利带在身边，教他关于家族生意的一切，也就是铁路。快进到1900年，科利斯去世了，亨利以为他会继承南太平洋铁路公司。但董事会不想让另一个亨廷顿掌权，所以亨利出局了。他得到了一笔安慰奖，也就是5000万美元，这在当时
was about, maybe like, $400 million today. And he takes his cash, and he goes south to Los Angeles. The city of Los Angeles really shouldn't exist. I mean, because, you know, the LA river was a mess, and it was so prone to flooding when actually changed its location on the map. The only decent harbor is Long Beach, but San Diego has a bigger center of commerce. And downtown LA is like way far to the east. A disconnected flatland, but where many people saw the desert, Robert Barons of the late 19th century saw something else, a blank slate. So the modern city of Los Angeles, as we know it, was created as sort of like a counterweight
大约相当于今天的4亿美元。他拿着这笔钱，去了南方的洛杉矶。洛杉矶这座城市其实本不该存在。我的意思是，因为，你知道，洛杉矶河是一团糟，而且极易发生洪水，甚至改变了它在地图上的位置。唯一像样的港口是长滩，但圣地亚哥有更大的商业中心。而洛杉矶市中心离东边太远了。一片互不相连的平地，但在许多人眼中是沙漠的地方，19世纪末的商业大亨们看到了别的东西，一张白纸。所以，我们所知的现代洛杉矶市，是作为一种制衡力量被创造出来的，
to San Francisco, which was liberal even back then at very strong unions. And LA was an open shop, like a businessman, like Henry Huntington, had free reign. And he starts by purchasing the biggest transportation system in the city, which was the Los Angeles Railway, otherwise known as Larry. And he incorporates it into a new company
用来对抗旧金山，旧金山即使在当时也是自由派，工会势力非常强大。而洛杉矶是一个开放的商业环境，像亨利·亨廷顿这样的商人拥有绝对的自由。他从收购城里最大的交通系统开始，也就是洛杉矶铁路公司，又称“拉里”（Larry）。他将其并入了一家新公司，
called Pacific Electric. I talked to a bunch of historians about this, including Bill Friedrichs, who grew up in Los Angeles. I have this vague recollection of a street car running up and down the main drag, which was brand boulevard, and I think I can remember the bell ringing in the street car. Really, what did it sound like? Ding ding. Friedrichs actually it sound like? Ding, ding. I don't know. Friedrichs actually wrote a book about Henry Huntington. The key to Henry Huntington's operation
叫太平洋电力公司。我和很多历史学家谈过这件事，包括在洛杉矶长大的比尔·弗里德里希斯。我模糊地记得有一辆电车在主干道上跑来跑去，那是布兰德大道，我想我还能记得电车上的铃声。真的，听起来是什么样的？叮叮。弗里德里希斯其实……听起来是什么样的？叮叮。我不知道。弗里德里希斯其实写过一本关于亨利·亨廷顿的书。亨利·亨廷顿运营的关键
was that this was before a lot of regulation in the area. So Henry pretty much decided where development would occur by building a street car line out to the area, just ahead of development. And most frequently, he was building the street car lines out to where he owned the land. So, to put this in modern terms, the red car was kind of like the Kindle. Amazon loses money on the Kindle because they want you to use this e-reader as a portal
在于当时该地区缺乏监管。所以亨利基本上是通过在开发区之前修建电车线路，来决定开发会在哪里发生。而且他最常做的是，把电车线路修到他拥有土地的地方。所以，用现代术语来说，红车有点像Kindle。亚马逊在Kindle上亏钱，因为他们想让你把这个电子阅读器当作一个门户，
to buy lots of, you know, bigger stuff on their website. And so the red car was a portal to get you to buy other bigger stuff from Henry Huntington. Like your entire life. He never really made money with the Pacific Electric, but it took people out to his subdivisions where he sold them land, frequently sold them water, he controlled some water companies. He also established an electric operation called the Pacific Light and Power Company. It was essentially set up to provide electricity to his trolley cars, but he ended up selling electricity to the city of Los Angeles.
去购买他们网站上更多、更贵的东西。所以红车就是一个让你去购买亨利·亨廷顿其他更多、更贵东西的门户。比如你的整个人生。他从未真正通过太平洋电力公司赚到钱，但它把人们带到了他的住宅区，他在那里卖给他们土地，经常还卖给他们水，他控制了一些自来水公司。他还建立了一家名为太平洋光电公司的电力运营机构。它本质上是为了给他的电车提供电力，但他最终把电力卖给了洛杉矶市。
Now, even back then, this was not business as usual. There are lots of other street car developers, but they're much smaller and they frequently went bankrupt. Other developers owned land and they'd build a trolley out to some land, but not the immense amount of land that Huntington controlled. So he's sort of a complete package coming down. So from 1904 to 1913, Huntington opens 500 new subdivisions every year. He controls more than 900 red cars on more than 1100 miles of track. That's about 25% more track mileage than New York City has today, 100 years later.
即使在当时，这也不是常规的商业模式。当时有很多其他的电车开发商，但他们规模小得多，而且经常破产。其他开发商拥有土地，他们会修一条电车通往某块地，但不是亨廷顿控制的那种巨大的土地规模。所以他是一个完整的配套方案。因此，从1904年到1913年，亨廷顿每年开设500个新住宅区。他控制着超过900辆红车，在超过1100英里的轨道上运行。这比100年后的纽约市今天的轨道里程还要多出约25%。
Now, historically, American cities grow organically in rings out of a downtown. And Huntington really forces Los Angeles to expand outward at twice the rate. And I think that really weakened downtown LA because he was creating these little downtowns along his trolley routes. So, you know, you think he's creating this empire, he's got the trains, he's got the electricity, he's got the land, he's got the water. Only needed now, we're people.
从历史上看，美国城市通常以市中心为圆心向外呈环状有机增长。而亨廷顿确实强迫洛杉矶以两倍的速度向外扩张。我认为这削弱了洛杉矶市中心，因为他在他的电车路线上创造了这些小型的市中心。所以，你知道，你以为他在建立这个帝国，他有火车，有电力，有土地，有水。现在唯一缺的就是人了。
Back then, you know, there were a lot of reasons not to like cities. I mean, they were dirty, they were crowded, they were dangerous. And Los Angeles was gonna be this very different kind of city, That was the dream. In Huntington and Harry Chandler and all these other sort of LA power brokers went on this media blitz. And during the winter, they would blink at the Midwest with advertisements.
当时，你知道，有很多理由不喜欢城市。我的意思是，它们肮脏、拥挤、危险。而洛杉矶将成为一种非常不同的城市，这就是梦想。亨廷顿和哈里·钱德勒以及所有这些洛杉矶的权力掮客们发动了一场媒体闪电战。在冬天，他们会用广告向中西部地区狂轰滥炸。
You know that Los Angeles is a paradise full of orange trees. The climate will cure your asthma. You can go surfing. And surfing was actually a relatively unknown sport until Henry Huntington hired a Hawaiian surfer named George Frith to surf along Huntington Beach. And it worked. I mean, for a while, Long Beach was known as Iowa by the sea because so many islands lived there. But eventually, the dream went bust. So now, remember Pacific Electric is designed to lose money. It's a portal to Huntington's real estate and other companies. And so the board of Pacific Electric is not happy about this. And the meantime, the red car is becoming a threat to Southern Pacific Railroad,
你知道洛杉矶是一个充满橘子树的天堂。气候可以治愈你的哮喘。你可以去冲浪。而冲浪在亨利·亨廷顿雇佣一位名叫乔治·弗里斯的夏威夷冲浪者在亨廷顿海滩冲浪之前，实际上是一项相对不为人知的运动。这奏效了。我的意思是，有一段时间，长滩被称为“海边的爱荷华”，因为住在那里的爱荷华州人太多了。但最终，这个梦想破灭了。所以现在，记住太平洋电力公司是为了亏钱而设计的。它是通往亨廷顿房地产和其他公司的门户。所以太平洋电力公司的董事会对此并不高兴。与此同时，红车正成为南太平洋铁路公司的威胁，
which was the company that Huntington thought he was going to inherit from his uncle. So Southern Pacific wants to buy Pacific Electric. Huntington says no, his own board overrules him. He's forced to make a deal and once again his power and his ambitions are cut short. But Henry Huntington gets the last laugh in a pretty weird way. Because his uncle's fortune was split between him and his aunt Arabella. So Huntington marries his aunt and consolidates the family fortune. Now it's actually not quite as icky as it sounds, because they were not related by blood.
也就是亨廷顿以为他会从叔叔那里继承的公司。所以南太平洋铁路公司想收购太平洋电力公司。亨廷顿拒绝了，他自己的董事会否决了他。他被迫达成交易，他的权力和野心再次被缩短。但亨利·亨廷顿以一种相当奇怪的方式笑到了最后。因为他叔叔的财产在他和他的姑妈阿拉贝拉之间平分了。所以亨廷顿娶了他的姑妈，并巩固了家族财富。这其实并没有听起来那么恶心，因为他们没有血缘关系。
She was his uncle's second wife. But still. Yeah. So Huntington actually lives happily ever after, with his wealth and his aunt, his aunt, slash wife. And he brings a lot of beauty to Los Angeles. He creates Huntington Gardens, the Huntington Library. He dies in 1927.
她是叔叔的第二任妻子。但还是……是的。所以亨廷顿实际上和他的财富以及他的姑妈，也就是他的姑妈兼妻子，幸福地生活在一起。他为洛杉矶带来了很多美景。他创建了亨廷顿花园、亨廷顿图书馆。他于1927年去世。
And I don't know if he knew yet, but it was clear already to historians looking back that the red car was doomed. Red Car was doomed. Even though the overall track mileage rivaled New York, the Red Car wasn't comprehensive enough to go everywhere you needed to go by Red Car alone. And they started to become poorly maintained. People started calling them slums on wheels. The big turning point comes in 1926, a year before Huntington dies.
我不知道他当时是否知道，但对于回顾历史的历史学家来说，红车注定要失败已经很清楚了。红车注定要失败。尽管总轨道里程可以与纽约媲美，但红车并不全面，无法仅靠红车到达你需要去的任何地方。而且它们开始变得维护不善。人们开始称它们为“轮子上的贫民窟”。重大的转折点出现在1926年，也就是亨廷顿去世的前一年。
Southern Pacific, which now owns Huntington's Pacific Electric, offers this massive plan to build subways and elevated trains all around downtown LA. And this would be paid for by the taxpayer, so it's put up for a public referendum. And there's a lot of money spent, you know know a lot of advertising spend on both sides just like referendums today and the voters reject the plan People just didn't like Southern Pacific. They had meddled in California politics for so long that they called it the octopus Okay, so now remember the original sort of conspiracy theory that the car companies bought
现在拥有亨廷顿太平洋电力公司的南太平洋铁路公司，提出了一个在洛杉矶市中心周围修建地铁和高架火车的宏大计划。这将由纳税人买单，所以它被提交给公众进行全民公投。双方都投入了大量资金，你知道，就像今天的公投一样，投入了大量广告，但选民否决了这个计划。人们只是不喜欢南太平洋铁路公司。他们干预加州政治太久了，以至于人们称它为“章鱼”。好吧，现在记住最初的那种阴谋论，说汽车公司买下了
up the red car and tore them down and built up the freeways. So there was a subsidiary of General Motors called National Citylines and they did buy trolley cars and they converted them into bus routes. And there were people at the time that thought it was a conspiracy. This wasn't this conspiracy that suddenly, you know, people discovered 50 years later. But the fact is, specific electric was doing the same thing to their own trolley cars. As freeways became the norm and the red car became a thing
红车，拆掉它们，然后修建了高速公路。所以通用汽车确实有一个子公司叫“国家城市线路”，他们确实购买了电车并将其改造成公交线路。当时确实有人认为这是一个阴谋。这不是那种50年后人们才突然发现的阴谋。但事实是，太平洋电力公司也在对他们自己的电车做同样的事情。随着高速公路成为常态，红车成为
of the past, you can see how a conspiracy theory could become cemented into the public imagination. So when I first saw a map of the red car lines, I actually thought it was an early map of the freeways, which makes sense. These are the roots that people were using to get around. And in some cases, like the red car lines, I actually thought it was an early map of the freeways, which makes sense. These are the routes that people were using to get around. And in some cases like the Koenga Pass, trains were actually dismantled to make way for
过去的事物，你可以看出阴谋论是如何在公众想象中根深蒂固的。所以当我第一次看到红车线路图时，我实际上以为那是早期的高速公路地图，这说得通。这些是人们用来出行的路线。在某些情况下，比如科恩加山口，火车实际上被拆除以让位于
the Hollywood freeway. Santa Monica Boulevard is paved over a trolley route, and sometimes, you know, when I was heading to the 405, I'd actually drive over these phantom tracks. LA's first freeway, the Oroio Asako Parkway, which connects downtown to Pasadena, opened in 1940. A few years later, city planners proposed another plan for elevated railroads that was rejected by the city council. The last red car ran in 1961.
好莱坞高速公路。圣莫尼卡大道是铺在电车路线上的，有时，你知道，当我前往405号公路时，我实际上会开车经过这些幽灵般的轨道。洛杉矶的第一条高速公路，连接市中心和帕萨迪纳的阿罗约塞科公园大道，于1940年开通。几年后，城市规划者提出了另一个高架铁路计划，但被市议会否决了。最后一辆红车在1961年运行。
And you have to think it was in a way a victim of its own success. Henry Huntington's goal was to connect his far-flung properties and create a decentralized city that you'd need a mass transit solution to get around. The problem was he couldn't provide it. Over time, L.A. was so spread out that it overtaxed what the red car was capable of servicing. I like to imagine, you know, if it's 1960, I'm driving along the 10 freeway. I mean, I'm sure there was traffic, but it must have been pretty smooth, because I mean, the freeways that exist now
你不得不认为它在某种程度上是自身成功的受害者。亨利·亨廷顿的目标是连接他分散的房产，创造一个去中心化的城市，你需要一个大众交通解决方案来四处走动。问题是他无法提供。随着时间的推移，洛杉矶扩张得太厉害了，以至于超出了红车所能服务的负荷。我喜欢想象，你知道，如果是1960年，我正开在10号高速公路上。我的意思是，我肯定当时也有交通，但一定很顺畅，因为我的意思是，现在存在的高速公路
were the same freeways back then, but built for a much smaller population. So they must have seemed like a really impressive solution at the time. And today, Angelino's can appreciate the great solution of their highway system for hours and hours and hours and hours and hours and hours and hours and hours and hours. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Eric Mullinsky with help from Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars.
和当时的高速公路是一样的，但却是为人口少得多的时候建造的。所以它们在当时一定看起来是一个非常令人印象深刻的解决方案。而今天，洛杉矶人可以连续几个小时、几个小时、几个小时、几个小时、几个小时、几个小时、几个小时、几个小时地欣赏他们高速公路系统的伟大解决方案。《99%隐形》本周由埃里克·莫林斯基制作，萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯提供了帮助。
It's a project of 91.7, local public radio KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but we have pictures of red cars and red car maps and pictures of Henry Huntington at 99%invisible.org. Radio Tepi-U from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我在推特上叫Roman Mars，但我们在99%invisible.org上有红车的照片、红车地图和亨利·亨廷顿的照片。来自PRX的RadioTopia。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。